before we get started today we want to
let you know that yes we are coming
potentially to a town near you for a
night of unpredictable comedy and music
we're gonna be in Las Vegas on June 21st
Salt Lake City on June 22nd Denver on
June 23rd Milwaukee on the 25th
Indianapolis on the 26th Detroit on the
27th Omaha Nebraska on the 29th and on
the 30th of June we'll be in Minneapolis
Minnesota and then it's starting in
September we're gonna pick up in Houston
Texas September 4th New Orleans
September 5th Birmingham Alabama the 6th
Jacksonville Florida the 7th Tampa
Florida the 8th Albuquerque New Mexico
November 20th Phoenix Arizona the 21st
Sacramento California the 22nd and
Valley Center California November 23rd
go to rhett and Link alive calm for more
info and to buy your tix let's do a
biscuit
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're asking the question
what's the question
oh what's the secret to 18 plus years of
marriage it's such an important question
that you nearly forgot it we've recently
celebrated our wedding anniversaries
like I've been married to Christie for
over 19 years and as of the recording of
this you've been married to Jesse Oh
most 18 years we decided to celebrate
our anniversaries on your weekend
because it was Memorial Day weekend so
we get a three-day weekend which means
you celebrate your anniversary on your
anniversary and I celebrate my
anniversary a week before my anniversary
I'm forcing your hand now I will have to
then celebrate my actual anniversary but
it'll be a low-key affair
you'll be like remember a couple weeks
back when we celebrated this well it's
just a week back because my actual
anniversary is June 2nd which is you
know I'm not even gonna say when we're
recording this but it's a few days away
one day after your birthday big bowl
coming up I'm catching up with you man
I'm ticking over
what do you want gonna be the same age
same age that's happened a lot you know
it means more now though because 41
October 11 it's a lot more human the
first we're not the same age and then
from June 1st October 11th we are the
same age yeah I thought about that yeah
hey that's not this isn't about no
somebody sitting about our birthdays
this is about our marriages yeah and
we're gonna we're gonna expose all the
secrets right well I'm not gonna it's
not like I've got some thoughts but at
the same time I don't I don't I don't
want to set this up like hey we've got
the key to a long-lasting marriage even
though we did but if you think around
for 50 minutes you can find out the
answer we're gonna talk about our
anniversary trips what we did and any
hijinks that resulted from that Oh
and then hopefully find a landing point
which is the secret to our long marriage
yeah but before we do that I do want to
you're getting two ads already no I know
you say something like that I think you
about to do an app people already trying
to skip forward no don't skip this is
not an ad this is just an update because
when you turn 41 I would really like you
to come to my house so when you walk in
the door I can have a little surprise
for you you're not really you're making
it sound so enticing that I'm I'm
probably would never come to your house
you remember I've talked about this a
couple of times now the home automation
process that I have been that I have
been embarking on and if it's not if
it's not intermittent fasting it's your
light situation well the light situation
you need to fast from your light
situation on lock it is not quite I
haven't catered what's gonna haven't
catered your experience yet but all I
can tell you got something for me for my
birthday I mean I can really easily it's
just got a routine and I go in and say
don't don't don't
don't undersell it play it big if you're
gonna play it big let me just tell you
what I have done and I have devoted
even though I wasn't the one to actually
do the electrical work that was required
I can only imagine I would still be
doing it if I was the one that was
responsible for the electrical work
I was only responsible for bulb
placement unlike bulb insertion sorry
they're smart bulbs and they're smart
switches and this is covering a lot of
my house yeah I I remember the only
thing that he said you wanted every
single light source to be able to well
be controlled by your voice we're
basically they're just which I thought
was overkill given my experience with
the turns out that I thought that I was
gonna have to employ some sort of
numbering system like battleship but all
you have to do is say like living room
lamps living room main lights and you
got it covered dining room dining room
lamp I texted a ret the morning that
apparently this was being installed and
I was like so are you gonna come into
work today
oh no I did actually work a lot I gotta
stay here cuz my lights are going in my
switches are going in I'm like oh great
but let me just have lights to go let me
just tell you as a man who can now make
all kinds of things happen in his house
I listen I can say for instance I can
say here's Johnny I could say hey Google
which I just activated all your Google
homes you're welcome here's Johnny and
at that point all the lights will go out
all the lamps that have the multicolored
bulbs and them which I got those bulbs
that can be like 16 million different
colors they all turn red okay and then
the main title from the shining place
and then my youngest son begins to cry
it's just all part of being an excellent
dad every light turns off the ones that
can turn red turn red and your whole
house is red and it literally looks like
there's a demon coming from the bedroom
like I were downstairs last night oh you
installed a demon hologram no but like
you know like what do you mean no you
think about this you're downstairs and
there's all this red light around you
and you look upstairs and there's a door
prax and coming out of the door is just
red light it feels like a horror movie
like I found my own self getting scared
and then I realized that my kid was
crying and I was like I gotta back off
on this but I can do that I also I'm
sure it didn't take any time to set that
don't know and I bet you're gonna use it
all the time
well Ivar it my kids got so into into
doing it that I was I was like by the
end of that was like boys I'm gonna make
it where the frickin Google home can't
recognize your voices if you abuse this
I started realizing where it could
backfire but also if you say here's
Johnny
too much if you say hey Google its
Shepherd because Shepherd wanted his own
situation okay all the lights dim he
doesn't like it to be dark all the
lights that can dim dim and then all the
lights that can change color turned to
violet
his favorite color okay and then Bruno
Mars Versace on the floor place and then
what he just no this is what he does so
he got I got it all set up for him and
then he was like mom come in here and he
laid back on the couch he put he he laid
back on the couch and he put his hands
behind his head oh and he said I'm gonna
start saying hey HG for hey Google okay
Hg it's Shepard now the only thing
that's a little bit underwhelming about
this I'm gonna prepare you so when you
come and we say I gotta come at night
obviously you got to come at night and
it's not as fast as it should be first I
don't know what's happening so it's like
hey Google it sorry HG its Shepherd and
it's just like two seconds pass all the
lights go out another second passes the
lights turn violet two more seconds pass
and then the music starts you want it
all to happen at once and I think in the
year 2021 it will all happen at the same
time but it's 2019 I'm ahead of the
curve yeah if they if it this would be
the type of thing that like in the
creative meeting for the commercial they
would be pitching this cheetah and they
never said well you know we're gonna
have to put a note on the screen that
said edited for time yeah you know yeah
it but they would still sell it that way
I can also make the whole house seem
like a dungeon with people screaming in
different locations and his different
lights coming on and off but it's it's a
horror movie mode a horror horror
haunted house mode I'm a dark I'm a dark
individual don't do anything that wasn't
wicked twisted or insane yeah what you
can make it you can do like a space
escape like a lunar landscape where it
turns it turns to the house blue and
then plays like moon music that's not
creepy that's awesome so you know how to
work into something no actually I can I
can discern no practical value for it's
called impressing people once that's the
practical value anyone who hasn't seen
it at least you're honest I mean because
that's all of it yeah but it's fun it's
here's the thing now but you've also you
were people so controlled you have some
practical stuff right I mean have you
not made it we're like it's sunset
certain lights turn on oh yeah yeah I
thought was different times at night to
turn off step one was every single the
morning morning this happens every
single night like literally sunrise and
sunset you have it respond to sunrise
and sunset and then when I say HG
goodnight all the lights in the house go
off and then when I say and then when we
if Jesse wants to have a party she says
HG it's party time and then all the
lights here's what my wife does when
we're gonna have people over she goes
around cutting on all the lamps and
getting everything right I said it the
way that she wanted and I say baby all
you got to do is tell Google it's party
time and it will set everything the way
you want so all that was taken care of
and then once I had all that done I was
like where else can I go from here and
that's when I started getting creative
but let me tell you as a man who can
literally drag himself around his house
never having to touch anything and can
control all this just this weekend I
installed the last bulb and I was like
this is everything that I ever wanted i
sat down on my couch as my entire house
was bathed in red demonic light and I
was listening to the shining theme and I
thought this can't beat all there is
that's good that's good
because
I was gonna say I've noticed a phrase
that you've said a number of times as
you as you bragged about your lights and
that phrase is as a man so let me ask
you is that what this is about uh and
I'm just saying as a as a human nothing
as a male it really is this about your
manhood no no it's not about my manhood
what I'm getting at is that and you know
me and this is largely what got a lot of
questions about you Amanda this this
this is what largely drives me and makes
me sort of the driven person that I am
is that I see something and I can visual
like I can visualize that moment that
I'm gonna be on the couch having just
said here's Johnny and all the things
that I described happening and for that
moment to take place I will do
everything to get to that point right
now I will make everything that needs to
happen happen to get to that point but
then inevitably when I get there I'm
like what else now what what else you
know I mean okay now I can control
everything with my voice do you have any
motorized blinds no but I definitely I
have a hub that is repaired for them I
do well I got him in the bathroom
so I'm just saying I'm already you own
that front and you can draw him with
your voice
no you easily can though you need to get
the Lutron hub as a man I I don't feel
the need to control the movies I can
control it with my finger well you want
me to tell you what happens when I say
I'm in my bedroom and I say hey Google
it's business time nope definitely not
because there is a program that it
follows at that point as well and I'm
not making it up
the only thing I don't have get it the
one thing I don't have is I don't have
the motorized blinds which I told Jesse
I was like you know when we read because
she wants to redo the bedroom I said
well you get the motorized blinds and
when I say it's business time the blinds
all go down to I'm a blinds open guy you
know you want your neighbors to be
intimately familiar with you well it's
not about there but like I just don't
see the stars
to daylight whatever man Oh in the daily
yeah it doesn't happen in the daylight
I'm saying that the blinds don't go down
in the day in the daylight don't go down
in the nighttime I think all of this
raises a specific question which is very
much on topic today not about lights at
all it's about how on earth could
someone be married to Rhett mcLaughlin
for 18 years you know I think that's
what it brings into focus for me at
least someone who caters your it gets
the perfect environment for you to make
love and I think that that's that's easy
to stay married to someone someone who
has controlled their house to be
conducive to lovemaking that's I think
that's it that's an asset
that's not something to overcome hey
let's not forget all the other things
like hey honey I made it I made our
house into a sonic dungeon
she uh she didn't like that that much
anyway list let's talk about our trips
but first we are going to talk about the
shirts that we're wearing and I said we
sell stuff you can wear it and it'll
make you feel connected to a greater
purpose I've got a shirt that purpose is
up to you I've got a shirt that says ear
biscuits on it it has the two of us on
it which is weird because the two of us
are currently making an air biscuit
right think about that you can get this
a mythical dot store you can get these
mugs you can get everything that we sell
at mythical dot store or our amazon
store if it's not there this is a shirt
that I'm fond of what do we call it
mythicality
that's the connectivity from the
mythicality z' is it where is that
available right Amazon now is that I
still it store a mythical dot store go
to mythical dot store we'd love to see
it when you post your pictures we repost
those on the mythical Instagram feed so
let us have it let us have it
hashtag mythical merch thank you for
supporting entertainment
okay so where'd you go I went to Malibu
man I got a a private house like I'll
say I got a Airbnb in Malibu that was a
house all to ourselves but it was a
guest house and I do need and I will go
into more detail about how this house
was set up because the surroundings were
quite interesting but I was very excited
to have a couple of nights away just me
and Christie to reflect on our 19 years
of marriage and I was really excited
because I went yeah i'm a fan of Airbnb
I'm a fan of renting a whole place and
now you got to bring all your own stuff
but I'm the type as opposed to a hotel
where they'll clean up after you
everyday and like you can order room
service and you can you can do about I
know you did something like that and I'm
not dogging that I'm just saying that
those are all amenities that you don't
have an air B&B that's a factor but for
me an overriding factor is there's a
there's a there's more privacy and
there's there's more of a sense of
control
I already bring so much crap and I do
want to tell you some of the stuff that
I brought for a to night for at room for
2 night trip because I'm just I don't
know if you know but I'm a little I'm a
little peculiar about the things that I
like to have you're in order to make
things perfect I'm familiar with this
but for starters I'll just say that I
found this place on Airbnb that was um
it's on like a studio apartment
situation type guest house and it was
right on the beach like there was a
little kitchenette a little living area
a little bedroom area all kind of
connected in one space and then the
sliding glass doors the whole front was
just two sections of sliding glass doors
and then one sliding glass door on the
side and then you'll have to walk
downstairs to the no there's a deck
right there and there were like two
ooh big loungers and then right on the
other side of that you you step down off
the deck and you're just on the beach so
like the like the water doesn't come up
onto the deck the water the water came
up to the the high tide line came up
probably 20 feet from the edge of the
deck Oh
usually don't get that much beach in
Malibu at those houses it's like yes
sometimes a lot of the houses are built
literally over the high tide line so the
the the waves will crash like right
under your on the foundation under your
deck so it was a perfect spot where
there was always a little bit of beach
but I was like whoa this is quite a find
I mean there's not a lot of places that
you can rent out in Malibu and if you
are you're renting like a whole house
and you're paying a crap ton of money
and there's and you're you're like
setting up you're not doing with a lot
of done that and you're not dealing with
a lot of people because this is like a
private area like so there's now but we
were walking by they say all the beaches
of private but they're no beach can be
made private but there's there were
signs on all of the decks around there
that said the people private property
the people try to say this is a huge
actually a huge dispute although try to
say that it's a private beach but
technically the sign says private from
the mean high tide line and up to the
house there's an app that I have on my
phone I can't remember it's like Malibu
beaches or something like that
yeah it's an app that someone who was
upset with the homeowners who were
keeping everybody out from the public
beach is made to show you the all the
access points to all these beaches
because they're like there are no
private beaches and you can go right
behind somebody's house if you want so
that's where we elected to go tell me
where you went and then we can kind of
ping-pong I went to Palm Springs stayed
in a hotel I'm not going to say the name
of the hotel because I'm gonna be
talking about people that I saw there
and you know I don't want to betray I
don't and also I'm gonna be complaining
a little bit okay I probably will go
back to this place maybe I wanted to I
just want to keep the name unmentioned
okay is it like Red Roof Inn
yeah it's the Ritz the Ramada
it's you know it no it's a nice box a
nice a nice hotel in Palm Springs and
again Jesse Jesse I I'm I'm pretty
flexible I the air air BnB versus hotel
is I'm kind of open I'd see advantages
and disadvantages to both jesse is she's
all about the hotel experience she
doesn't she likes to she just basically
is like I don't want to have to be
cleaning up after everybody I want
somebody to do it for me and because
you'll make a mess and and our boys are
just animals
they're just animals you didn't bring
your boys no no I'm just saying but like
she's dealing with them there it's like
having two very large ferrets you know
I'm saying it's just a pee everywhere
your family's clean my family's not I
think it's older parent they're all
they're squiggling everywhere
leaving poop in your hand and please
don't please don't say but first make
great pets I know
ferrets don't make great children that's
what I'm saying okay and that's what I
have anyway so she want and she also
being able to goat we discovered
recently that the idea of going and this
comes into play later the idea of just
going and sitting next to the pool and
chilling out and not having any
responsibilities and being able to read
or write whatever you want to do
coupled with people watching which is an
especially nice thing to do in Palm
Springs especially at a place like this
hotel we were very primed for reading
lounging and people watching okay that's
what we were ready for I was not ready
for any people watching but don't let me
forget that like it it ended up
happening and you reminded me of it so I
need to say yeah all right so in
preparation for my trip I was so excited
you know I was I was like weeks ahead of
time I was making a list I was like man
we're gonna it's gonna be cold it's not
gonna be like by my definition like
sixty degrees is cold I'm in like I need
a beach and especially in a California
beach okay but don't understand it get
in the ocean yes you got to have a
wetsuit and we got to be
like a ferret to get any all right I got
a ferret charm yet have a fur first it's
so cold that only what is it about
children and again I didn't bring my
children on this trip I'd like it you'll
dip your toe in there like any total
water be like oh I might die if I
submerge like pass my heart and then all
of a sudden some kids are sprint and
vine they're just like frolicking all in
it they don't they have they're
impervious to temperature they can they
can swim around and all these like
frigid temperatures like is nothing like
what is that are they stupid yeah well
yeah they are they're a little bit
stupider for sure it's in it it's not
like whoa this is so coldest
invigorating they don't say anything
about it they're just in it they're just
like oh this is fun cuz I'm in water I
don't think they develop the nerve
endings that we have you know fully
developed nerve endings so I'm like I'm
gonna make a list cuz I don't want to
forget anything that's important to me
and I wrote on the list like cozy
clothes and then I went I was like i'ma
bring sweat pants that does a brawl
under cozy clothes I said I got to get
specific well I'm cozy clothes in
sweatpants are two different categories
the subcategories of God list had bullet
points and then like or sub bullets got
it under cozy clothes it has sweatpants
and then it had diapers those thinner
sweatpants old t-shirt and then it had
like those pajama pants and then it had
my slippers mm-hm
my bedroom slippers and then it also had
open if if I'm gonna I know that I'm
going to shower the shower was
disconnected you had to walk across a
little bit of decking to get to the
shower shower the only shower here to go
outside the shower had a toilet in a
sink and it was like an outhouse but it
was in between the guest house and the
main mansion which was right on the
other side and I imagine I knew this
from the pictures that this was just a
guest house connected to a mansion did
you meet the mansion people was not
connected I'll tell you in a minute so I
knew I on my list I had to have some
flip-flops cuz I'm gonna be taking a
shower on on it like a decking don't
want to get a splinter I'm gonna get a
splinter or athletes first and then I'm
like I'm bringing my own pillows I'm
bringing my own blank
it's oh gosh multiple blankets because I
know how it'll be if I'm wrapped up in a
blanket and then Kristy is like well I
don't have a blanket I'm like I got you
like it too we both had blankets we both
had pillows and then I'm like you know
what did you bring a trailer like a
tractor trailer and all your stuff in it
no all this fit inside my vehicle
because it was all mushy everything I
packed was like no company was
compressible and then I'm like the PSD
resistance never been done before I'm
bringing sleeping bags and I'm not
talking about I'm not talking about just
like a little sleeping but I brought I
was like I need to get these things out
anyway let him air out
they've been stored up for a couple of
years since we haven't been camping I'm
gonna bring out my mummy bags cuz I I'm
like beach sleeping for just Beach
lounging like even if I'm on the lounge
chairs or laying on the beach like I'm
like the Sun the stars are gonna come
out and we're gonna lay on the beach and
it's gonna be romantic but it's gonna be
freezing and I bet you we're not gonna
want to do it unless we like can be in
like 14 degree rated sleeping bags
because I'm very cold natured right so
we got these like the mummy bags that
come over your head and you can only you
can only see your eyes and like your
nose if you elect to put that out of the
hole it's very romantic yeah I was so
excited man I got all that stuff and
then I'm like and we can't forget the
foods like the comfort foods because
again I can't order room service I got
to have it with me right there's not a
lot of places where it's your own room
something like two grocery stores in
Malibu doesn't have any anything I don't
you'll say there's like a market yeah I
don't know how the markets big now it's
kind of like lots of frou-frou shops huh
there's got to be something yeah it's
Malibu and I'm like all right we got a
Kristi loves cheese cheese going on a
list we both gotta have some fruits like
some raspberries and blueberries and I
got to have my peanut butter you're
still on the list by the way I'm talking
like you're still on the list of things
I'm not even there yet yeah I mean just
haven't even arrived yet and then I'm
like chips like I don't eat chips
normally I'm like
if this vacations gonna be made I'm
gonna be snuggled up in a sleeping bag
on the beach eating chips and I'm like
and they got to be those ruffles sour
cream and cheddar chips those are the
jam and look I told Christie I was gonna
get those and I was like and you know
what lays now has unruffled enriched
normal lays sour cream and cheddar
flavor I saw him in Ralph's they put the
sour cream before the cheddar or you
just mix that up they call it something
different they call it I think they call
it sour cream cheddar yeah
keep people guessing and I told Christie
and she went to the store she's like
they don't have them but I got the
ruffles and I got Pringles sour cream
and cheddar okay we got lots of Huff's
few days later I'm like we don't have
enough Lacroix I got to go back to
Ralph's cuz we're still prepping and
then she's leaving and I we haven't left
yet I'm driving home and I meet her as
she's leaving and I hold out the window
Lay's sour cream and cheddar chips so we
so we get there we get in our cozy
clothes
we both had on camo sweatshirts and camo
sweatpants the ones we sell on our
website we were so comfortable well and
we were just we were having like a good
mythical morning tasting like that was
the first thing we did was we broke out
all of the sour cream and cheddar chips
and started tasting them we figure out
which ones are the best and you weren't
even there
and which is the best the ruffles the
rough if you didn't get better than
ruthless they they started it the lays
were kind of unnatural it was like I
know what I know what lays should be and
I know what the experience is and like
sour cream and onion like there that I
mean they're the best they're the best
chips but you start throwing cheese on a
lays something something goes a little
sideways but those ruffles the thing you
come to associate with it was its it's
still the best at Pringles I don't you
want to talk about it Kristy loved him
but Prima's aren't even chips to me
don't even I don't even want to talk
about it well don't I took a very sleep
what'd you pack I took a small suitcase
that I packed approximately 30 minutes
before I walked out the door did you
bring us did you bring a sleeping bag
for like the poolside I no sleeping bags
No
no blankets interestingly because it's
been unusually cool here it's actually
unusually cool there it was like 85
degrees on Saturday which typically this
time of year would be over 100 yeah and
polish that's kind of perfect for
poolside situation it's perfect if you
if you get to the poolside just turned
out to be a little bit of an issue
you couldn't find the pool no I found
the pond the pools I found two pools but
they were completely filled so Saturday
water with people and water and people
and no places to sit well I'm gonna let
me back up a little bit cuz I got to
just kind of ease into this now I'd
heard about this play first of all you
go to Palm Springs on Memorial Day
weekend in a nice hotel you're in
there's a high possibility of seeing
someone that you would recognize from
from the inner world of entertainment
right that sort of close proximity to
Los Angeles in Palm Springs whoever and
I kind of heard that this is a place
this is a people watching people spoting
kind of place hot spot I pull up in my
car to you know have them you know
welcome us to the hotel or whatever I'm
right behind a family that's cool that's
gotten there at the exact same time with
us and that family was Michael Richards
and family Kramer from Seinfeld
yes and interestingly so we check in
basically right next to them and then I
saw them around and I saw Kramer and the
in the in the hot tub and stuff and in
the nature of the conversation that
Jesse and I had which is just I will
have it again with you it's just like
you got this guy who I when if you if
you had to tell somebody who you didn't
know who Michael Richards was who
Michael Richards was you'd probably say
what you say well he was on this famous
show yeah he was a tall guy in Seinfeld
he was super funny and he would uh you
know he had a license plate on his car
to set man
but then and he every time he walked in
everyone would cheer in class but it was
awesome but then there was a controversy
because he went he got belligerent at
like a stand up somebody was filming him
and he spouted some racial epithets yes
like as bad as it gets and what year
would you think that that was only 2004
Oh 2006 I was like I thought it was 2006
so 13 years ago right this guy who was
known and beloved for playing this
character does this thing that now like
when you go to his Wikipedia entry it's
like that's kind of the thing that you
find and okay so in so we're talking
about a guy who was cancelled before
people got cancelled you know I'm saying
like now we're in the hole cancel
culture but yeah this is back when you
you really had to do you had to lean
into it and you had to something to get
cancelled so you got cancelled and I was
in like he doesn't do stand-up anymore
i I don't know I know nothing about the
guy did you talk to him no I didn't talk
to her you just talked about him yeah
but he was just interesting cuz I was
like I just wonder what this guy's life
is like now I mean obviously same as
yours apparently obviously he you know
he made enough money and probably
continues to bring in a lot of money
with the syndication of Seinfeld I don't
know how that works but that he's able
to go to this hotel and he's got it
family and whatever but yeah he's did
because of that thing he did in the in
the conclusions potentially rightfully
so that people came to about him because
of the thing that he did that's just
what it that's just what he's known for
it was just kind of an interesting thing
to be like I look at this guy yeah and
that's what I'm thinking about and he
knows that's what everyone's thinking
about do you know what I'm saying it's
just an interesting thing that that can
that kind of whether you want to call it
a mistake or whether you wanted to call
it he was just being himself and and his
true self came out whatever you want to
say however you want to judge that that
is what people know him for and it was
just an interesting thing to just be
around it but that was kind of what
you're looking forward to people
watching now you got this fascinating
case study and like public perception
yeah and I'm like is he constantly it's
surely he's no longer constantly
thinking about it because you couldn't
live your life if you're constantly
thinking about that but we'll move on
from Michael Richards that you didn't
find what you didn't find a place at the
pool you saw him when you checked in I
just saw him what I checked in ok so
that so then then the the next morning
we decide well we had already made
reservations to get a massage when you
go it's another thing you don't I don't
get you don't get in an air B&B unless
you call somebody any when you call
somebody in for massage things get weird
no there's other ways to get a massage
I'm getting alright so we went to this
but they had this incredible an
incredible spa that was like Seiler
themed it was it was totally ridiculous
but in a very interesting fun way I
would like to retract my statement
earlier by the way ok after 19 years of
marriage there is no let's be real good
recovery I mean we're not gonna we're
not go sit around it it's like give each
other massage
we pay other people to do that exactly
right and other things we can do but
massages and requests
well no interesting ok again this is a
this is a Seinfeld this is a Seinfeld
reference that I didn't realize until
right now but we get there
and the woman at the front desk says I'm
like I'm here for our 9 o'clock massage
or whatever and she's like oh I need to
inform you that we only have male
masseuse is available is that ok and of
course my knee-jerk reaction is to be
like yes of course and but then the
George Costanza in me is thinking yeah
well I'm not as comfortable with that
and and I don't know I don't know why
right
yeah I've gotten an all male massage
before but the funny thing is is Jessie
said as we were waiting she was like
it's it's interesting that both of us
both of us are more comfortable with
receiving a massage from a woman and now
because we're receiving massage from a
man it's it's it's different and I was
like you know what but it's not really I
just I've never gotten a massage effort
from a man so I was like but you know
what I'm at palms
it's no different I'm gonna lean into it
I believe I had the best massage I've
ever had I am still sore because you
didn't make it sexual or he was just
good at it
well I've never I've never made a
massage sexual at this which is the
weird thing but isn't there like what
some like that's hot yes George
that's the George gets to hold the whole
episode was about if it's not sexual
which is not it's somebody rubbing your
muscles in a technically non intimate
way they're rubbing your muscles for the
clinical wafer in like a therapeutic way
way but because we're animals were
humans you naturally interpret the touch
essential right there's oil involved
there's music playing the lights are low
there's rubbing involved I mean all the
ingredients are I mean of course I
didn't say it's business time a spa I
didn't say it and it didn't turn on my
lights a certain color that I like
particularly and low on my shades and
play and playlists that I've
meticulously put together but everything
else was this is a sensual environment
but then in the mall and so then it was
like so why is it that if you sense this
as a slightly sensual sensual
environment that therefore it makes you
more comfortable if a woman is the one
doing it what is this what is this kind
of exposing what does that say about
right right and so I quit I got out of
my own head and I was like I'm just here
for a massage and it was I mean I'm
telling you it was the next level well
if you wanna I mean this guy found parts
of me that I didn't know I had in any
robot he worked me so hard that's right
in a completely non sensual way that's
great you know what and it's totally
professional there yeah so and now you
know what type of energy you need to
bring me every massage well and then I
started thinking that I was having
sexist thoughts about masseuses I got
through with the massage and I was like
that's the best massage I've ever had
and I was like I might say
that because it was a man what's wrong
with me no I just think too much man
well I think you need to think more but
just quietly my wife fell asleep
oh really did you hear a snore yes she
doesn't fall every single time we had
couples Muslim they're not is not not
enough pain just towards the end though
she told me she told me before we went
and she said if I fall asleep and start
snoring you have to say something and
then it happened and I was like that's
almost over yeah I just let it ride and
then she woke herself up she snored so
loud really you know I've done that
before it feels it feels weird when
you're like oh how long have I been out
they just been I mean if you know you
could gently just stop and the masseuse
could just like take a breather right
you know it's like to keep working it
yeah go on their phone yeah one hand on
the phone would that's why I didn't get
a spot of the pool because the early
morning massage and then you get out to
the you get out there at like 11 o'clock
no spots the grounds are incredible so
we we went and we set in some chairs
somewhere and then we couldn't got in a
hammock and read people that was awesome
but we didn't get to do the people watch
or people saving no no lounge chairs
heavy tricks I hate that they have a
strict no saving policy because they
know that they don't have enough space
so they say that if you're gone for 20
minutes it'll move your stay move your
stuff so we put our names on a list and
we literally never got called oh we
didn't get called never went to the we
eventually got into the family pool onto
the family pool but there were kids
there that sucked and that's when I met
another person of note but I've been
talking for too long so what else
happened with you well as you can
imagine we got our chips we got our
blankets we got our sweatpants on that
next morning I mean we went to a nice
restaurant that first night you know but
that first day there was no was no one
on the beach in front of us it was like
it was I was almost eerie that there
wasn't I mean this is Memorial Day
weekend there's nobody on this beach
because it's like it feels like a
private beach and there's not many
access points and on the access points
there's not much parking like Malibu is
again
it was it was kind of extraordinary to
get this place but it's designed to keep
the people out we laid on our lounge
chairs and we we watched the ocean and
just kind of talked and hung out and you
know ate our chips tried to figure out
which ones were the best I told you the
answer to that but it was it was
glorious I told it I told Chris he after
a while I was like you know we're
sitting here we're watching these waves
just what with with as much intention as
we watch an episode of Game of Thrones
it's a and I use the word intention I
mean there's a little bit of a there's a
meditative aspect to the waves and I
began to reflect on it and I was like it
kind of feels like when you're camping
and you just find yourself staring at
the campfire you know that's one of my
favorite things about camping is that
yes you could be on your phone but
you're not tempted to like go watch Game
of Thrones in your tent you're like
you're mesmerized by the fire and in a
very similar way
we're like mesmerized by the ocean waves
right there just just beyond I shot of
our toes well or the end of the sleeping
bags and my reflection was I think that
there's something about being so close
to something so powerful as either fire
or the ocean and knowing that you're
completely safe but there's this like
constant you know it could kill you if
it got out of control especially what
when you're in a sleeping bag but you're
right there get in the ocean and it
sleeping bag especially one of those
monkey up around your eyes you're goner
yeah you go into the bottom yeah
fast but there's there's something about
there's something meditative about
sitting there and like you know what
there's people who they have they like
live on the beach and they like get to
know everything like some dolphins
started coming by
you know sometimes we'd paddleboard we
paddle board over the pot of dolphins
like you see them come by and then you
get to know the birds and you the more
you sit there with like a little
discipline to like not do anything else
we didn't even read a book the more it
the scene kind of comes alive like oh
there's birds over there and they're
diving into the ocean it was in
explaining it it doesn't seem that
special but that was a very special
moment for us and then you talk about
people watching all of a sudden this
bodybuilder dude
shirtless bodybuilder bald behemoth with
big muscles comes down and he like he
had headphones on he takes his
headphones off he doesn't see us and he
like puts him down on the beach in front
of us and then does your camo and then
he we were in camera and and like these
two dogs run up to him I was like oh
they were there his dogs and then he
gets out his camera and he starts his
phone it's Cameron his phone and he
starts he goes into this like he has a
camera on his phone yeah pretty crazy
anything goes into this like what long
drawn-out photo session we've lexing and
leaning over and like taking pictures
how close how close are you to this man
how does he not see you well there was
some grass kind of growing in front of
us and we were kind of hunting down and
whispering about hiding from him but I
did film it I would say he was about um
I don't know I'd say he's about 30 yards
away but I'm not a football player were
the dogs in play the dogs were in the he
was taking selfies with him and his two
dogs
he was as flexing dog pictures yeah and
then that's a fetish dude was like had
bulbous muscles like the ones on your
shoulder and on your back traps lats he
had it all man
and he was taking photos and like we
were watching him and we started to feel
uncomfortable like I started to feel
like I needed to make noise Boop yes hey
man we're here yeah you're being watched
sir
and that but we didn't and then when he
when he got done taking his photos for
his Instagram apparently then he's like
putting his headphones on and like
getting his dogs back on the leash and
like Chris is like he's gonna see us and
he likes cans back this way he just
sauce imma give him the thumbs up yeah
gave him a thumbs up and then he didn't
stare at me he just kind of like I could
tell he saw me and then acted like he
didn't he's like oh now I'm I play it
cool like I meant to be here I knew you
were watching it's fine thumbs up then
he walks away and I look over and I
wanna make this mansion beside me this
is interesting there's no signs of life
there it's a huge like 1990s era modern
style like white with just windows all
over it
and it was clearly on the same property
and we were in the guest house but
there's no signs of life there and so I
I walk over there through the gate I'm
like oh there's a gate there but beyond
the outhouse and I look in and it's like
it's gutted the freaking panting
mansion's gutted like they thought they
were they halted in the middle of
renovations and I'm like I'm a course
now I'm gonna check all the doors to see
what if any of them are unlocked because
I want to explore this place is huge the
only door that was open led to the yeah
you're surprised eyebrows going out led
to the basement so I opened the door and
then there's like a long staircase down
to the basement it's pitch black so I'm
like I got to go back and get my phone
for my flashlight your phone has a
flashlight on yeah dude what I'm tell
Christy I'm going down in this basement
she's like I'm staying here in the
sleeping bags good I turn on the
flashlight and I go down there and it
smells like a basement and there's like
this room with like padding all over it
and there was this cymbal cleaner and
I'm like oh a musician used to like a
drummer used to drum down cymbal cleaner
okay it was like just creepy basement
and then I realized oh the light
switches turn on lights do the work so I
turned I put my flashlight away I was
still kind of creeped out and then there
was a wine cellar your trespass that had
no wine anywhere except one open bottle
of champagne on the floor and I'm like I
didn't drink it or anything but it was
kind of creepy and I'm like man what if
I get caught down here and then I walked
over and I opened this door and there
was I can't believe I was doing this
alright okay can you believe that I do
this I'm like surprised something you
would do but I'd be too afraid to do
this I was like what would rut do
he would open this door and it was a si
elevator what so I get in the elevator
no no I'm not getting in the elevator
yeah I'm stuck in somebody's abandoned
elevator yeah that would suck so then I
came back and I told Christie about it
I'm like yeah the house is gutted and
this is what I found and we and I just
kept lounging but after that point I
just couldn't help but keep looking over
there that mansion and then just to skip
ahead when it got dark I felt myself
getting pretty creeped out about this
mansion and I started to realize when we
walked down the beach earlier today
there were a couple of other mansions on
this one particular Street that this
guest house was on and all of the homes
were under some stage of reconstruction
or renovation and it had been halted and
so on either side there's two huge
mansions nobody in them abandoned and I
started and as the Sun went down you
transported into another time I said I
just started to get creeped out by it I
was like is this gonna ruin my night
because I just started feeling like
zombies could be in there or something
it was just it was post-apocalyptic this
one particular beach access private road
had all these mansions on it and for
some my theory is some weird Malibu
zoning regulation issue everybody had to
stop renovations and like no one wants
to buy or sell or move on this stuff but
this one guy he like put up the guest
house on Airbnb it was very clean and
nice and new but I mean on one hand it
was creepy on the other hand it provided
like complete privacy on either side
because these mansions that were looming
over us and like all the windows are
open there's nobody in there and in it
national dog man is just he's just a
visitor he had walked down from
somewhere else so I would say if I had
to that was the only drawback was like I
was a little creeped out by the fact
that like we were in an abandoned
neighborhood basically it sounds pretty
cool to me man I was creeped out I
didn't want to tell Chrissy but you know
Chrissy didn't seem to be creeped out so
I didn't want to tell her I don't think
it's that creepy I mean you know how
there's like we were staying in one of
the house
like there's like Instagram fees there's
like abandoned porn I think that's what
it's called yeah well yeah not abandoned
for ruin form
yeah ruin porn it's basically just
people taking pictures of architecture
that's been that nobody's inhabited it
for like yeah I'm a big fan of that I
have a whole book about that
they're just got different when you're
camping there we are gonna get to the
secret to a long marriage I do want I
wanted to tell one more story before
whether I learned I think I'm kind of
answering it along the way but okay I I
saw someone else while we were at the
pool now first of all we were at the
pool and be Seinfeld Kramer's in the hot
tub and we're sitting there lounging and
we finally got this part of the fant as
a family pool and I'm trying to get away
for my kids I got all these freaking
kids like playing games and yelling at
each other and splashing horrible it's
what happens at the family pool that's
why there's an adult's only pool but it
was too freaking filled so anyway I'm
sitting there just despising children
that they even exist and then and then
they all of a sudden they say excuse me
everyone out of the pool what first of
all I wasn't in the pool I was on the
side never got in the pool didn't touch
the water thankfully oh no I think a kid
took in the pool or really I don't know
what happened but they made everybody in
30 minutes had to pass and they like
clean some stuff and they put some some
chemicals in there you know it in the
meantime somebody doing some logging
lots of people kept showing up and
starting to get into the pool and
because Jesse and I were seated right
next to the corner of the pool we became
the pool police know so I literally had
to wait for people to get on me like I
got sorry guys you're no one's supposed
to be in the pool now after four times
you waited for them to get in first
though no no cuz I was reading I'm
reading and then I would look up there'd
be somebody with putting their feet in
the pool you can't get in there they're
doing their cleaning so then Jesse was
like you need to tell them to put a sign
up because we shouldn't have to do this
we shouldnt have to be the pool police
that's right but then a family walked up
and did it up was like I was like oh
it's that guy and he was getting ready
to get in poo I'm like I
you can't get the pool right now there's
some there's chemicals or something in
there and then he said something he was
British he had a quick sort of response
like thanks for the radioactivity were
learning or something like that and I
was like that's the guy who crap that
guy's in everything it's one of those
guys like have no idea what your name is
sir but I have and I can't even say what
the last movie I saw that you were in
but you're in everything you're a
world-class actor I just kept you and
your family from getting into a turd
pool and you were glad there wasn't a
sign so then I was like I just saw a
movie with this guy in it I just saw a
movie and this guy was the villain he
was the villain Shazam
he's the villain from Jim's Shazam oh I
thought when you realize something you
just now said Shazam I got it
he's from Shazam turns out of course I
still don't know his name right so then
I have to go on IMDB and follow the bald
he's the bald guy from Shazam his name
is Mark Strong okay and you have seen
this man you know who it is and not only
was he and she sent this guy is is has a
just a storied acting career I mean he's
been in everything well what are you
doing like are you you were asking him
this what have you been in no I know I
cuz I'm on IMDB and he's well he was in
this and then I watch all sitting there
in your lounger on IMDB and then I watch
our WatchMojo thing on YouTube of all
the his top ten performances and of
course this is so hold on right there in
the lounger no no no no no no no he had
left you were still in the loud you're
watching yeah watch my welcome to a mark
Strong wormhole and he was somewhere
else on the property enjoying himself
and then that night we go to the
restaurant we sit down mark Strong and
family come and sit down next to us and
I'm just kind of listening into his his
convert that into his conversation with
the waiter as he orders he orders with
so much gravitas in authority I mean it
was it you just you gotta be around you
know you wouldn't understand it till you
were around mark Strong or at least in
close proximity to him this guy's a
class act
worrying these type of things too Jesse
everything every time I saw him because
Jesse got so annoyed I started leaning
into him I said I would be like
world-class actor strong is here a he'll
be like one of the greatest actors of
our time mark Strong and family just
arrived to the restaurant okay and she I
had a good time with that it works for a
while she thought was very funny that
she thought it was annoying and then I
did stop never talked to him but uh it's
pretty thrilling you know the only other
people I saw were at the same spot as
the Sun was going down these two girls
in bikinis came up and they started
taking pictures apparently for their
Instagram yeah and it's not an easy
thing to do they didn't see as either
and for 20 minutes they're sitting there
taking pictures looking at the pictures
not being happy taking more pictures
good the girl showed up in bikinis and
then they would take they set up the
camera with the timer like on the
backpack and then they would get up she
would run and like pose beside her
friend stick her butt out yeah you got
to and then she would look at the
picture and then Kristy would be like
yeah too much butt and then she would go
back and she would do it again and she
would turn her butt and it wouldn't be
out of fahren like Kristy knew exactly
what she could read their minds too much
but and then the one girl she put on
jean shorts
I gotta have a George shot and then the
other girl put on pants yep
and it got less and less interesting to
me you know why they do that it make it
seem like they were going back all trips
be like oh this is this is you can post
multiple times you can have you know
this is when I went to the Jean this is
when I went to Malibu that day more
jords and this is what I went and I wore
fooled jeans and this is when I went and
I just had a bikini bottom on I think
it's so that you can scroll right I you
know I'm on Instagram again now
shout-out to link Lamont you can scroll
right and take their clothes off like a
paper doll oh well yeah that's a
different thing though scroll left put
the clothes back on
yeah that was my best guess yeah you got
a really line yourself up well to do
that it you know it's also an Instagram
Winston did you see a nipple unless it's
a male nipple well they didn't get naked
I take it down hey didn't get naked but
I wasn't gonna move I mean
and I wasn't gonna stop watching because
hey this is my spot on the beach you
just happen to be here
he was it it was entertainment yeah it
wasn't dolphins or in storage it's not
due for a few minutes not Mari strong I
mean you know mark strong stayed he wore
a state strong long-sleeve black shirt
and black shorts long-sleeve black shirt
I was like this guy's a bad man look at
him really he's wearing black do you see
any selfies happened I bet he doesn't
take so he doesn't have any camera don't
have a phone mark strong doesn't have a
phone I don't need a phone no he has
gravitas
you can immune Akay twith mark strong
with smoke signals man
maybe you sleepy letters maybe hint mark
strong only responds to handwritten
letters really I could tell just by
looking at him you write him a letter
then he burns it and send you a smoke
signal be exact that's how you know he
got it he doesn't write letter right he
only reads letters he said smoke signals
in response you got to know how to read
him his agent and manager they know how
to read those smoke signals now getting
to the secret to a long marriage
I've been married 19 years I've only
been married 18 years and not even that
cuz that's not till this weekend but my
wife was a reading I don't think you
gonna make it no I believe I will
my wife is reading a book now this is a
you know it's interesting because I feel
like my wife is I we've been in a
relationship for a long time but I can
count on one hand the number of books
that I've read about relationships
whereas she probably needs both hands
feet in some other limbs that I don't
even know about to count how many books
she's read about relationships yeah that
probably says a lot more about you uh I
think it also just speaks to her
capacity for self betterment and
learning about you know she's just she's
she's she's a better person she's a
better person than I am
same thing with Christy in terms of like
her reading those type of books right
like either parenting or like
self self-improvement or relation might
be it might just be that we're perfect
and we don't need it but I wasn't gonna
be the first one to say that anyway
she's reading a book called mating in
captivity which I thought okay all right
handcuffs what is that about
it's Esther Perel who is written I think
I know it she's like a relationships
expert and she's written this book
that's super popular at this point and
just she's like reading it and based on
this question it's a it's all about and
again I'm speaking from total secondhand
knowledge of the book having just been
next to someone in a hammock who was
reading it that's the kind of source
that I am here but Jesse would like stop
and I say something and like it led to
conversations about our relationship
because it's all about this interesting
paradox that exists in long-term
relationships and that is the fact that
the sort of the separateness and the
distance that you have with someone that
you are just meeting just getting to
know drives the desire and the sort of
the romantic connection between two
people it's that unfamiliarity that you
have with somebody that you're kind of
getting to know and falling in love with
that draws you closer but then so love
kind of closes the distance between two
people but it's the distance and sort of
the separateness and the tension that
fuels desire and so what happens in a
lot of relationships over the long term
is there's so much familiarity that
there's no more mystery and then people
start thinking well I'm not even
attracted to this person there's there's
no desire here it's just this love
relationship and she in this very
exquisite way kind of breaks down this
from a psychological perspective I'm
definitely gonna read the book at this
point based on just a few things that
jesse has told me but we were kind of
talking about that and there it in and I
think that I would say
the in relationships first of all
relationships can last for it can be
indefinite if people are just committed
to each other are just committed to the
idea of staying with each other and
there's lots of people who just stay
with each other for external reasons for
the sake of children because they
believe that divorce is wrong whatever
the reason is they just stay together
because of some expectation but it's not
actual a desire to stay together right
so I would say that in relationships
that are long-term like we're saying
like over the course of several several
years or more or whatever 10 years or
more I don't know I think that one of
the keys to people continuing to be
together in a healthy sort of vibrant
situation is something that they've done
either intentional or unintentional we
can talk about that has led to there
being enough of a separation and
distance and mystery that has maintained
some level of desire and of course
that's going to AB and flow over the
course of a relationship but I so
fascinating concept because I think that
people all the time they say like you
got to spice things up in the bedroom
man you know you got it you you you you
got to get Google involved you got to
have Google to do things automatically
because if not it's gonna seem like the
same old thing and this repetition and
familiarity if you're a normal human
eventually you're gonna be like where's
the mystery what what is there left to
talk about there's a Jason Isbell song
that talks about the old couple sitting
across from each other in the restaurant
and they basically got nothing else to
say to each other
he's got nothing else to learn about his
heart or something like that is the line
and it says in it's like baby let's
never get that way is the is the worst
of the song and I think that it's having
a desire to never get that way where you
got nothing left to talk about now I
don't have anything any prescriptive
thing about it but what is your initial
assessment of that dynamic well first of
all that the title of the book made any
captivity so the captivity is marriage
so it seems like it's it's framed in a
negative way which I find it
then it's like you're you're trapped in
this in a committed relationship but
obviously that's not I don't want to
thrust no no no it's the book it's it's
it's basically as far as I understand it
it's about finding that kind of passion
and desire and in knowing also that this
is how like you it's almost being
familiar with how the human mind works
the house the understanding it isn't
that people like people are like I was
so in love at one point and I just don't
love you anymore I want a new romance
this happen again and again and again
and again infatuated she actually talks
about the hormones the hormones that are
predominant in that falling in love
initial romance sort of spark those
lasts for a certain time in the name
Wayne but the hormones that actually
contribute to things like cuddling they
last a lot longer and last way into deep
into a relationship well it's
interesting because Christina were
having a discussion when we were
sleeping bagging it up like enjoying the
dolphins and the the mesmerizing ocean
and the instagramers I don't remember
what got me talking about this but it is
related to your point and that is I said
have you have you ever do you ever just
have this overwhelming sense of being
alone because I I rarely have that sense
you know it's like I've always I've
always had never lived alone
I've always had a roommate and then I
moved from having like a college
roommate you and our other friends
directly into you know living with her
none of us none of the four of us have
ever lived alone and I was like
sometimes I think in more than like the
meditative zone of being on the beach
and like having that discipline that I
talked about to take in the environment
and appreciate it and find entertainment
or whatever you know you find
fill-in-the-blank in it without trying
be distracted I did have this
overwhelming sense of like there is an
aspect of being there's a certain
autonomy to like no one can ever be
inside your own brain you know no one
can ever be inside your own
consciousness at a certain point when
you boil it all down you are
encapsulated and alone you know your
you're your own entity as much as I
share with Christie there and I so I
asked her that because I was like but I
I I rarely feel that and I actually
think and I told her well I asked her
the question first I said do you ever
feel that way and she was like yeah a
lot I have a sense of being alone I mean
and sometimes that translates into
depression like you're saying like a
sadness of yeah a sadness of being alone
because and I think and I said sometimes
I just go to the bathroom and shut the
door and don't I don't even poop just to
be alone but having an overwhelming
sense of being lonely is is an aspect of
depression it can't it can't be so she
was laughing at me that like I had not
experienced that and I feel alone and I
and I talked about it as if it was such
a foreign concept so to many people
including her it's not and she was able
to laugh in that moment which I thought
was beautiful and I was like I think the
reason why I don't is because I just I
run from that feeling it's not that it's
there but that I spent a lot of my life
not being comfortable with the sensation
of loneliness being a and I equate it
with being alone with my own thoughts
being alone with myself I mean as
connected as Christy and I are we're not
the same person so there is that tension
that I think what you said made me think
of that because and again I'll come back
to it one more time I think one of the
keys to
being together for 19 years and
anticipating being together the rest of
our lives that's absolutely the plan and
having a confidence in that is I mean on
a practical level we're just so
compatible like everything that I said
about this trip like making my list and
the things that I valued and like being
in comfy clothes and this like the fact
that I wanted to design our anniversary
vacation in the way that I did and it
seems so perfect to me and like Christie
thought it was funny the things that I
was doing in terms of like putting chips
and cozy pants on the list but at the
same time I knew that she was also
really into it like and it's just that's
just a case study and how I think we
we're very compatible when it comes to
the way we think and our tastes and like
the way that the way that our brains
work the way the things that we value at
the same time we have changed so much as
people from who we were 19 years ago
yeah we're totally different people and
I know that you and Jesse as well as I
know you guys in many aspects are
totally different people
we've grown so much we've encountered so
much in life and with everything you
encounter the big things and the
cumulative effect of all the small
things that you wouldn't even put on a
list are all opportunities to grow a
part or grow together so and I think
just the glue of our compatibility has
allowed us to face change and continue
to develop as people like in a parallel
path but but I also think that it's not
100 percent parallel and we don't always
respond to things that happen in our
lives in the same way or think or
believe the same things or agree on the
same things or whatever at every point
well and I would and there's that so I'm
getting that there's that autonomy of
yeah we're there is we are individuals
going through life and the other and I
think it says
that's that's key and I get high I
wouldn't have I mean I did say and I
think I said it on your biscuits at some
point when I was taught I was talking
about this exact same thing about the
fact that we had changed so much right
and and Jesse and I have changed in
parallel but in in in different ways and
at different rates and in different ways
at different times and that has created
tension at points right it's created
there have been points at which we were
so much on a different page that you
might be in I don't think we ever really
started to realistically think about
this but there have been times in our
marriage we were on a different page and
you begin you have those thoughts who
are like is this the beginning is this
the beginning of us growing apart
forever like sometimes you're like is
this is this what it feels like when you
start to grow apart now thankfully each
and every time that has happened it's
ended up kind of fueling this once we do
get on the same page or there's some
sort of reconciliation or whatever it's
this dynamic that she's talking about in
the book which is like now the desire is
renewed and you feel like you're moving
into a new phase there's this I got I'm
not talking about you gotta have a
little instability in order to maintain
long term stability I'm not I am kind of
saying that but not saying that you get
to have purposeful instability I'm just
saying that it has helped maintain a
certain freshness and a sense of
adventure in the fact that tension we
both we both are really committed to
like change like we've kind of embrace
change and there's like sort of like
striving for personal change some of
that has been intentional as some of
that has just happened to us there's
life circumstance or whatever but I kind
of feel like there's been a number of
key points where I felt like we're like
embarking on a new journey just as a
couple not just as in our relationship
but just that what we're doing in life
it's the same thing it's like I remember
a good friend of mine talked about
talked about his wife getting a getting
a sort of a drastically new haircut
uh-huh and and he the way he was talking
to it he was just like it's like a whole
new woman you know and his point was is
that that kind of like oh that you can't
ignore that that is that's a dynamic in
the way that people think and I guess
some people might need that more than
others but this willingness to like be
like I'm going to kind of I'm gonna
change I'm change I'm changing myself
I'm evolving you're evolving you're
changing but underlying all that change
is this commitment to be like well we're
doing it for the betterment of ourselves
but we're also doing it for the
betterment of our relationship long-term
like you got to have there's got to be a
sense of commitment because you can't
just rely on this ooh the romance comes
and goes and I just gotta keep hoping
that it keeps coming back there's not an
underlying commitment to be like no no
we're committed to each other then it's
not gonna work and I think it's a yeah
there's a the foundational commitment to
love each other which involves lots of
times putting the other person before
yourself yeah you know but I think
there's also a commitment to continuing
to like each other that matters a whole
lot it's a day and it's a different
thing right it's like and I feel like we
I did have a mentality that was like
okay we're gonna early earlier in in
marriage that was like okay we're gonna
we're gonna figure this out and we're
just gonna have a plan and it's all
gonna you know we're gonna agree on
everything and everything's good there's
gonna be security in everything being
aligned we're gonna be like those
couples we're just gonna start looking
alike and being alike and we're gonna
become one person and that happens quite
a bit by the way and it happens in what
would otherwise be considered and could
be considered happy couples in a sense
and that they're committed and they're
together now but I don't think I'm not
beyond that there may not be a lot of
sparks in that relationship but it's
solid and is committed but I think there
was a shift in the fact that like you
know when life throws crap at you or
whatever the case may be
you just you're changing for whatever
the reasons that
embracing that as an opportunity to to
work through that with another person
that you're committed to is it can be
extremely rewarding but it but it might
take a while but knowing that I just I'm
not even I'm not just I'm not just
falling back on a commitment to love but
I'm also pressing into a commitment to
like yeah definitely I think and I and I
would say that the another key we're not
this is not a comprehensive exhaustive
list it's just some observations but I
think that well I know that
communication it not there's I'm sure
there's couples who don't talk about
this nature of their relationship or the
or the quality of their relationship and
how it can be better and what are the
issues and that kind of thing and they
may especially I would say that like
baby boomers and older might be in a
relationship where it's like there's
they haven't talked about their
relationship in 20 years but they're
like what else are we gonna do while
it's what what else would I do where who
else would I go to this is stable this
this gives me what I need but I would
think especially for our generation and
younger that's not gonna work you know
what I'm saying I think that you've got
to be able to talk about your
relationship like Jesse's reading this
book and she's like two stops and like
ask me questions and we have a
discussion about it and I'm gonna I'm
gonna read the book with an intention
that well what does this mean about our
relationship I mean this this goes for
anything this goes for friendships and
anything right like you got to stop
every once in a while and actually talk
about it I mean we've been we've been
talking lately about we just kind of we
know couples who know couples who are
like young married couples and like
they're like they haven't figured out
their sex lives at all because they will
not talk about it
you know you know what I'm saying like
they're so not on the same page because
they haven't broken through the
what I guess I guess for some people is
this awkward barrier to be like let's
talk openly about what it is we're
hoping to accomplish what you want what
I want yeah and that goes for every
single area and I would just say that
one of the injesting I talked about is
like one of the things that has kind of
gotten us through these transitions and
these changes in these ups and downs and
learning all this new stuff about
ourselves is just the fact that even
when it's been hard we've talked about
it when we weren't on the same page we
were talking about not being on the same
page we didn't just knock we just didn't
get off on the we didn't get on
different pages and then stop talking to
each other there was we there maybe in a
few days where we weren't talking about
it right but we would always get back to
like alright let's have it let's have an
open dialogue about our relationship I
just don't see how it can continue
without that and I mean to kind of bring
this to a conclusion ultimately I'm just
going to take a position of being I'm so
grateful you know having over 19 plus
then two plus years of dating you know
everything that Chrissy and I have been
through individually and together I'm
just grateful that everything is an
opportunity to bring you closer or to to
send you apart a little bit and it and I
and sometimes both one thing can do both
and in in either order you know it's
it's such a it's such a dynamic thing
every relationship but I can't I can't
think of any more dynamic than you know
with a with a partner like being married
it's just I'm just I I just cannot take
credit for us being together and like
with the stuff that we've listed out and
the insights that I thought we feel like
we have a lot of it is just look well
yeah and it's just luck fortune blessing
whatever you want to call it
I'm extremely grateful that we find
ourselves that that I've had the
privilege to go through life with
someone up to this point and know
someone so well and still be loved and
liked it's it's an amazing feeling to be
at like looking at the twenty year mark
and knowing that I've got something this
special that like I hoped for but knew
there were no guarantees that it would
happen it's it's but kind of become like
the the thing that especially in Los
Angeles when you say you've been married
for 18 or 19 years people are like is
he's a joke you guys been married that
long well I like to interpret it as oh
you look so young first of all but then
once I get over that is not being the
reason and when again and I and I
completely i completely agree with
everything that you said that this is
not based on listen i don't i have if if
i know anything it's that i know a whole
lot less than I thought I did at 20 I
know a whole lot less than I thought I
did at 30 yeah do you know what I'm
saying like with every year that passes
I'm just more aware of how little that I
understand it's kind of its kind of
intimidating and how much is left to
learn about the world and myself and my
wife so I'm not saying that we've done
anything we like I feel very like what
you said very privileged that it's
turned out this way because I'm sure
there could have been some in some in
some parallel universe there you know
there was an event that happened in the
relationship of rhett and Jessi that was
too much for them to bear you know what
I'm saying
and I've avoid I've been able to avoid
that it's not like I know there was that
thing I can point to that was we almost
didn't hang on but we did it's like no
it's like like I said the
been ups and downs but this has been an
adventure of growing in partnership with
somebody that I still when I think about
I get to go away for a weekend I'm like
I get to go with her away for a weekend
and that's something that I want to do
you know it may be that strong guy will
be there too if Mark Strong is there
it'll be even better or just a strong
guy with dogs world-class storied career
best actor of our generation mark Strong
he looked happy in his marriage he's
probably he's he's 55 years old sorry
mark if you but you can go on high in
deep IMDB and figure that he looks like
he's been with his wife for a while got
some teenage kids looks very happy sure
if Mark Strong wants to come on we don't
even have guests anymore but if Mark
Strong wants to come on it talked about
how you have a strong marriage you're
welcome anytime sir you can replace link
you can sit right there and that's it
match that seat I'm all for it all right
you got a rec for us we love our wives
but much more importantly they love us
that's the extraordinary part that is
the crazy part sure I got a rec for you
man man I don't I feel like this is
gonna be this is a music recommendation
oh dang this is gonna be it's gonna be
polarizing oh not for the for the
youngsters out there they're gonna be
like okay I'll check it out and I'm cool
that's cool but like I'm gonna recommend
age'
by Steely Dan I'm gonna recommend the
whole album and I'm gonna acquire it and
then i'ma recommend that you watch
classic albums series on the making of
that album because these you know these
guys went into the you know
now but when they were living they
decided to stop touring as a Bailey and
an Steely Dan became like a studio band
and they're like these like ultra
perfectionist like making this pristine
studio music but the song aja aja that's
a wild ride man
and that's also the name in the album
yeah crazy album they turned Michael me
the song peg is on there they turned
Michael McDonald's backup vocals into
like us like it's like a synth like a
synthesizer like that got him to sing
and they mixed it in that way it's it's
crazy it's just very every choice that
you could make musically they made
unexpectedly on purpose and the most key
there you know to be a Steely Dan fan
like really is like a very D key thing
to do it's like what is uh what
activities do you recommend to do while
listening to it laying in bed with
headphones on why your wife sleeps just
I go to sleep before my wife oh well I
wouldn't I wouldn't do it while she's
awake it's just listening to music such
a weird such a weird ride that song it's
like a weird amusement park ride music
okay AJ Steely Dan alright this has been
another year biscuit a little bit longer
we baked this one a little bit longer
for you but we didn't overcook it
hopefully lots of love marriage beach
and pool life let us know about what you
think the keys to along a long committed
relationship are or a strong
relationship specifically if you're mark
strong I'm willing to read anything that
you do let us know with hash tag ear
biscuits will interact let's interact on
on the Internet
thank you for speaking next week I love
you and I like you to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]